[Music]
hello everyone welcome back for another
exclusive tip interview here at the
Collider suite I am very excited to be
talking to the team behind hearts and
bones right now just to jump into it
because a lot of folks out there do not
know what your movie is about I assume
then you want to give I feel like I have
to yes you look the film is about a war
photographer who's returning home and
he's approached by a South Sudanese man
who he had photographed 20 years earlier
and the film becomes about their
friendship and a mystery that is I guess
unraveled through the film that revolves
around a central photograph but it's
ultimately about friendship and this is
your first scripted feature moving over
from making a documentary why make the
move with this particular story that's a
good question I I really wanted to tell
this story it was built upon a lot of
experiences that I had with people I'd
met throughout the community in Sydney
and so it was really pieced together
through real-life experiences and in
that I think there's a documentary
element but it felt like it needed to be
told in a type mystery drama fashion it
also was informed in some way the
genesis of this started before quite
some time ago but it was informed by
Ben's last documentary as well that the
the spirit of it what was what's going
on between the two men it sort of
informed yeah I just remembered that I
was reading that you had read the script
a long long time ago right does does
that happen to you often where you know
a script will cross your desk and then
years later a new version of it will
come again and you'll go for it yes
sometimes absolutely and yeah it was
just something that Ben was working on
and then went away and was pursuing his
documentary and then there was another
iteration of it and we we kind of
clicked with that script and take pretty
much straightaway went and caught up
with each other and I was on board and
and you're speaking of first features
this is this is your first feature and
it just sounds me because there's
something else in this so how did
I'd come about for you were you
interested in performing before yeah I
was actually looking forward to and
until they see been coming around and
you it's real now yeah it's a sighting
thing to do it's very real and something
you should be very proud of I'm curious
what were some of the biggest questions
you actually for all three of you that
you had for been because I feel like
this is the kind of movie that doesn't
necessarily give any easy answers in the
end which makes it a very interesting
discussion piece so for all of your
characters what was the biggest question
that you had for Ben before jumping in I
just knew I had to do it minute I got
the script it was it wasn't about
whether I should do it
it was I have to do it and whatever I
have to do to get the role I would do
because I just hadn't seen a woman like
Anushka before I mean she was written
just just going in to audition for her I
could feel her I could I could sense her
and I knew her and yeah it was it was
probably the best gift I had did you
guys have any questions about your
characters before you started shooting
the film oh you have many but uh I
suppose the question from me or the the
conversation for me with with Ben was
was primarily maybe correct me if I'm
wrong was about tone and and and because
we're sort of in it feels like in many
ways if there has a sort of documentary
camera camera there's a sense of that
feels like the very very true very real
and so we're working with professional
actors and people who haven't acted
before there's some improvisational
scenes it's a very guerrilla film unit
just sort of what what town are we
striking and wasn't something we really
we did talk about but was something that
kind of became apparent us we went along
was just like finding finding that place
that we could all exist in in a very in
a in a very true way that was the thing
that was most sort of present in my mind
do you think that someone who didn't
have a documentary background like Ben
could have made the film quite the same
way and actually what is it like working
with Ben as an actor's director given
his background compared to other
directors you to work with Ben feels to
me like he's made about four features
before this and very calm very book very
prepped he's written the script he's
grown up on film sets all his life so
very very in control but very flexible
as well so really breezy and easy I'm
sure it doesn't feel like that inside
but that's that's happen it was very
collaborative it didn't feel like I mean
I'd come to him with something as simple
as and that because I did a different
accent in the movie and if I felt that
in a certain part it should be it should
sound a certain way he was so open open
to that and yeah it just felt that it
wasn't a director telling you what he
felt should it should be how it should
be done and no other way it was more a
conversation and I think that's quite
rare you know in the industry so working
with Ben with with that and with Hugo
for me it was just a whole learning
experience on how to not just work with
others but I don't know I'm gonna
probably make you blush more and make
myself cry but um it's just the humanity
of it and just listening to another
person and listening to what they have
to say and in encouraging them and
that's how I felt I felt so encouraged
on set not just by then but by both Hugo
in and Andrew and literally was the best
set ever
yeah I remember something also for me
though it was my first time Ben is a
very special person because the way he
started with me it was actually very
gentle with photos and then going over I
don't know if we can find somebody who
is better than him know is the best and
there was a certain time that I was
thinking of something else so he pulled
me away from people and was asking me
question is everything ok so he asked me
these questions so I knew something was
not right that I was doing he wanted it
to be to that level and I'm not prepared
to do that you know so I started
adjusting myself to to the level that he
wanted me to you know so these guys
actually is everything is everything and
and also to meet yeah and also to meet
these guys here was a privilege to me
you know because the script was actually
very long it's a book you know but
having them around me is actually
comforting me and I feel really so
privileged to be with them I love movies
and making movies more than you know so
whenever I hear about a group of people
that come together and so wholeheartedly
believe in each other and support each
other while making an important story
and like I'm so happy to hear these
answers but Andrew I also wanted to know
from your perspective what was the most
surprising thing about making a movie
was there anything where you're just
you're standing there on set and you're
like oh like that's how they do it
yeah it's if cyclist is sound easy but
it's very difficult really difficult you
know repeating one time we're repeating
50 times or maybe more of one thing
doing one thing and plus the pressure of
camera and you
so we get use of that slowly until we
get to the level that was required you
know but it's very very exciting once we
got into that it was very very exciting
it's like we should continue doing it
every time I have two story points I
want to ask you guys about first off I
just was curious why it was important to
have the pregnancy in both relationships
I mean I think I just I'm very focused
on that right now because my sister just
had a baby so I kind of know what it
means to me but what inspired you to
include that so heavily in this movie
what inspired me was Balu day turning up
pregnant at the casting oh and we didn't
want to hide it we couldn't hide it so
that was autumn and she I mean in the in
the session there in the test boludo did
such an amazing test she bought her
young son Ian who was three at the time
and he was running amuck while she was
doing the scene and just absorbed it
into this quite a powerful testing scene
but it the pregnancy thing that wasn't
intentional it wasn't in the script and
we just consumed it and the the whole
thing about making the film was about
letting real life in and this was a gift
and I think just rode with it went with
it when you're in a situation like that
and you're auditioning for movies do you
walk in that room and you're like oh no
maybe I won't get this because of my
situation right now not only that um
just let's just be real like I I sure
anishka wasn't me she didn't look like
me shouldn't sound like me she wasn't
pregnant she the vibe was so not me and
this is again he didn't pay me to say
this but this is just a testament to the
caliber of a director and a human venez
he had to do a whole 180 on Anushka
because she didn't look like me
shouldn't have an accent and I walk in
do what I do what I did and he you know
has no problems to say you know what
we're gonna throw out that picture of
Anushka and embrace this person that's
standing in front of me and I don't know
that doesn't happen a lot in Hollywood I
mean unless you're Meryl Streep or Halle
Berry I guess that might might happen
it happened for me and yeah it just
never happens and for him to do that so
seamlessly easily just not only gave me
faith in that I could do this but gave
me that vote of confidence then that
belief that if he's gonna believe in me
then I better believe in myself and do
this the right do it right yeah explode
[Laughter]
that all of that worked out because I do
think it adds a really really meaningful
touching layer to this movie and it just
you know and it heightens the pressure
of the situation and the importance of
sending the right messages to further
generations the other thing that I love
about this story is how you incorporate
music because music is an important part
of my life and I think anybody in their
lives needs whenever they're having a
tough time something to turn to in order
to I don't know fill a void boost their
mood anything at all so whether it's
music or something else what is that
thing in your life that you turn to when
you're down or stressed oh I think in
this film it's definitely the back the
healing power of music isn't it so I
tend to turn to music but books
literature so reading and film and
nature the natural world going for walks
sunsets forests rivers good assortment
right there however you guys Jesus I'm a
Christian so for me it's my faith I just
put on worship music or just go into
prayer and I'm right where I want to be
it's a hobby
music is a hobby to me and doing it in a
group as well it's extraordinary because
it's connected to that thing they seem
that the people are in the water you
know and the words it says going a road
which leads to nowhere you don't know
where you come from you don't know where
you're going and what you would meet
just be in tune to that water
and someone else will pick you up you
know
and the hands is the hen will turn like
like God's hand you know it was really
really important to have it all day so
he did a great job to pick it up and
then actually came up with some of the
things that I never knew someone else
would would come up with in in Western
world you know he came up with some of
the words like in Illinois or any layer
at your own that was in Arabic he is the
one who came up with you know too good
and too good it returns it means that
you know very interesting anything for
you then especially also as you know a
first-time narrative feature director
when you are just up to your eyeballs
and stress when you're worried about
something one what is the thing that you
turn to in order to kind of bring that
light into your life but also what's
your onset advice when you're super
stressed and need to relax oh look I
think for me I think what calms me and
grounds me is connecting with people and
I think that's a really important theme
in the film but I think it crosses
documentary I'm fascinated by people and
their stories and I think even in the
stress of making the film just to step
aside and talk to someone and connect
with someone and say what's going on or
how's life and start talking about
something else for a moment apart from
the film it gives everyone perspective
and I think that it reminds you that
that's what we're all here is to
understand each other and so that
actually gives me a lot of a lot of
peace so yeah it makes it all real and
we've all got lives and you know outside
of all of this so that's that's what I
wanted to remind everyone in the making
the film as well guys thank you so much
for your time this more you're kicking
off my day at TIFF on a really high note
I appreciate that and a huge
congratulations on the movies in Sierra
Leone eye out for hearts and bones a
thank you to all of you for watching
this interview do not leave without
liking and sharing it and before we say
goodbye a huge thank you to our
wonderful sponsor Nordstrom Canada we
could not be here covering these movies
without them so thank you we'll have so
much more TIFF 2019 coverage coming your
way real soon